welcome to the community wellbeing
meeting do we have any apologies please
I guess we have apologies for lateness
for two councilors with
oh they probably haven't no no so there
are no apologies could I have someone
move the apologies please
thank you Richard seeking to be
all in favor
carried are there any conflicts of
interest
there are no complex of Interest so item
one we have active Southland their
annual report to the 30th of June 2023
and are welcome along Vanessa Jess and
Gemma
thank you for coming along today to um
to go over your report with us
so we're ready when you are
hello okay it works
um Kia or everyone called Jess storm
again tokawangawa just wanted to
acknowledge
um Rex Susan and Keith for welcoming us
all and for you all having this time for
us to come and speak also want to
acknowledge the events of last week and
um send our support and and
um
I guess acknowledge the work that the
councilors and the council staff all did
last week so without further Ado we put
the report to you each six months
through Gmail and just felt like with
the change of CE for us and a new
Council here it was a good opportunity
to come and meet with you talk a little
bit broader about what active Southland
does in the Eastern region and also talk
about what some opportunities might be
for Partnerships
um
this whole hand over to you
Vanessa Huey poll chief executive of
active Southland and thank you again for
the opportunity to speak so very briefly
because we know we're time time limited
we wanted to walk you through a little
bit about the Journey of active
Southland so whoever has the clicker if
they could click on to the next slide
please
thank you
so it didn't work before so much
there it is perfect thank you
um so just very very brief overview is
um active South and was established in
1990 as the Southland Sports foundation
not long after it was renamed as sport
Southland which is a bit of a misnomer
because over the Journey of its of its
life the organization has had work and
focus across not just sport but also
physical activity in its broadest sense
including health and well-being outcomes
so this journey of who we are came to
fruition not so long ago in 2021 when we
rebranded as active Southland which more
closely encompasses and reflects the
work that we actually have done for a
number of years it's fair to say that
innovation has run through the veins of
the organization over the years with
many Pilots being undertaken in the
southern region on behalf of national
entities such as sport New Zealand so
and that includes a number of Pilots
that are being run at the moment which
Jim are and and Jess will speak to a
little bit more closely
but the national entities such as sport
New Zealand have found favor with
um you know piloting and and trialing
out various opportunities to to learn
and bring things to life down in
Southland which I think speaks to
adaptability and flexibility and
learning as we go
uh
thank you
the organization firmly and deeply
believes in its purpose and that is
encompassed around individual and
Community well-being so we we have a
really deep belief of the role that
physical activity plays in the value
proposition that it holds not just to
community members but to Collective
bodies we think about groups of people
we think about our schools we think
about
workplaces and we think about
bodies that like to to connect and group
together that also includes councils as
well so we believe that the value
proposition both socially culturally and
economically has a very very strong
value proposition and we want to talk
through some of the evidence of that
today
um the next slide just shows you what we
mean by physical activity and we use the
frame to tahati NaNa which comes from a
framework from Mason jury which talks
about we are holistic beings we
represent physical physical space as
well as cultural and social and family
and whanau and so physical activity to
to us doesn't mean just playing sport
although that is an important component
of it we are talking about how we get
ourselves to work how we get ourselves
to spaces it's about how we engage and
how we develop as young people into into
thriving adults it's also about how we
live and learn and how we work and how
we play so just by definition when we
talk about physical activity we mean it
in its broadest sense
uh thank you and I'll pass back over to
juice
thanks Vanessa um as Vanessa touched on
we believe there's Play Active Recon
sport is a cost-effective investment
towards your local government well-being
outcomes and I know these are familiar
to you but we're just going to talk
through what we acted Southlands doing
and each of these well-being spaces
already that you um that you part of it
you found through the role that German
has so oh I'm doing that
um sorry that's right social and
cultural well-being
um evidence relating to the impact of
Play Active wreck and Sport on social
well-beings is quite um considered and
can be across three kind of broad broad
themes that we identify so strengthening
social networks we all know that
physical activity can bring people
together and provide connections
um bringing communities together
increasing a sense of belonging
improving pride and it can actually help
reduce anti-social behaviors in
communities
um
cultural well-being we see that there's
ties from participation
um in Play Active Recon Sport with
strength strengthened cultural ties
increased well-being from participating
in culturally relevant physical activity
as people have aspirations for what they
want to do in a culturally appropriate
way
so I'll hold it hand over to Jimmy
good afternoon everybody I know a few
faces around the room but I'm General
and I'm based here at our office in Gore
um one of our first
um
major pieces of work we have going on at
easterners through our healthy Active
Learning team so we've got two staff
plus their wider team based here at in
Gore servicing uh totally servicing 60
66 schools across Southland and 20 in
the Goran districts
um they work at a collaborative contract
between sport NZ Ministry of Eden
tufature alongside us and it's about
improving the well-being of children and
young people through healthy eating
drinking and quality physical activity
um one of their six outcomes we've just
got a picture up there of a local group
of tamariki who made the hikoi up this
week not too long ago and it was around
the outcome of strengthening in
connection with the wider community so
students from St Mary's matoda primary
and e-score made the trip up yeah as you
can see it was a beautiful day and they
were learning about the historical
um and cultural background in the
stories around how the hokanui hills
were formed through the story about
matamata and it's just an example of
those schools that are engaged in our
program that are coming together to
learn something locally as well as the
activity of physically trooping their
way up there that hell for anyone that's
been up there as well
so that's um a really cool outcome those
kids are learning and also putting it
into practice Esco students particularly
went back to school and did their own
interpretation of the story as well as
they'd understood it from the day some
some really cool outcomes that that
team's doing locally
their iconic moonshine Trail event we'll
be back again in 2024 which we're really
looking forward to I've just been told
it was 15 years this coming year I think
so that's really exciting with only the
one Mist due to covert for 2023 we had
502 participants across seven events
that we're up to now which is really
amazing we've got opportunities from two
kilometers in length through to 50. so
there's literally something for
everybody on foot or on on bike 29 of
those were first timers the oldest
participant was 90 and believe it or not
he does the 15 kilometer run of which he
runs most of it too so any youngest was
two six corporate teams we had 90 people
in our new two kilometer family event So
based in the new uh part of the water
race Trail that's Incorporated inside
dollar Moore Park we've done a two
kilometer event and that's around
encouraging not only our locals to pop
out to the park on the day but also if
mum or dad are off doing a longer event
and the other half of the family sitting
around dollar more they can come along
and join in on something while they're
there
so reflected in the fact that 66 of
those 90 signed up to do that on the day
um overall we had a 9 out of 10
experience rating for the event for 2023
so we're really happy with that and
we're looking forward to being back in
February 10 2024.
Community insights is really important
to us as an organization making sure
what we do and how we do it is based off
what our community members want and need
is really important to us the picture
we've got there was just of a recent
event we held at tulloch Park so
um I've been lucky enough to be involved
through Keith in the talent back
Redevelopment process to date and so we
started thinking about how we could
incorporate Community voice into what
was happening down there alongside the
community matoto community board members
and all the other players have been in
the committee for that project
I spent some time talking to local
stakeholders down in matoda and found
that actually the project and what we
wanted to listen to and take on board
from the community became bigger than
just talic park and so we focused it
more on what exactly was happening in
matoda what was happening now what
people enjoyed what people else were
looking for and what they thought they
could be better with the themes that we
worked with we went visited the schools
we went spend some time at the bunker
and we had our afternoon down here at
telek Park which was really cool
councilor Phillips was there with us had
some pizza
um we are currently just working our way
through our data and evaluation of that
at the moment but the intent is that
when that's all come together it will be
a
um a shareable document to relevant
stakeholders so we'll make sure that it
gets back here to advise things that are
happening that could be relevant to the
community sorry to the council for the
matoda community as well
a neighborhood play System project in
each school so this was one of the
pilots that Vanessa was referring to so
e-score was one of four original sites
for the neighborhood play system from
sport NZ and to as far as I'm aware it
was one of the only ones that's made it
as far through the process as it's
gotten so far
so the background for a neighborhood
play System project was around
understanding how various Urban systems
impact children play experiences and
support development of recommendations
towards ensuring play friendly
environments so 40 score it was based
around uh Esco Primary School which is
one of our healthy Active Learning
schools and the wonderful principal
there Wendy kitto she has been a major
driver and has really proven to us that
the having the right people with the
right passion involved in projects like
this is a is a huge
um benefit to something like this we
also had the council involved in this
Keith and his team have been heavily
involved and it was Community led by the
tamariki they went around they took
literally took photos of the things in
their community and talked about why
they were good why they weren't what
else they would like to see
um as a result of all the hard work that
was put in down there there was a list
of recommendations and projects planned
out phased out and today there's been a
an amazing amount of work based off
Community voice that's actually occurred
in the Hamilton Street and Oxford Street
playgrounds if anyone's been down there
and noticed the new equipment that's in
place the new amenities that are in
place and there's obviously more to come
as funding becomes available to us
we hope that this truly hope this
becomes an ongoing and sustainable
Community project that has led by
Community themselves and the the ties
that it's got on with the community
members that are on the organizing group
for it we went to Wellington in May it
was to Recreation aotearoa's green pav
conference and Keith was there and Wendy
and myself and Wendy presented on the
project to an amazing amount of people
that came along chose to listen to this
story but I always laughed at her main
takeaway from her presentation was
you've got to get yourself a Keith if
you and if you haven't got the right
people involved in these kind of
projects then they just don't go
anywhere so having the right group of
people's made a huge difference for
escore and where that's gotten so far
and where it's going to next
through these
so the third well-being that we wanted
to focus on is obviously the economic
well-being and where play acts of wreck
and Sport can make a difference so
um support New Zealand suggests that the
economic value generated for local
communities and businesses through Play
Active Recon sport is quite significant
um if you saw on the Moonshine Trail we
capture where people are coming from and
a lot of people coming from out of town
employment of new zealanders into the
play Act of recreation Sports sector is
another significant direct contribution
harder and harder as you'll know too to
support that Workforce especially in
lifeguards and similar kind of roles and
managing them through through a career
pathway and productivity gains as a
result of physical activity savings for
communities as a result of the volunteer
Workforce and the economic impact of
major events which we've touched on
thank you
um we're very lucky to administer sport
nz's to mano active aotearoa fund from
via Act of Southland and for us over the
last year that looked like just over 87
000 across 15 organizations in east and
south and benefited from that fund
um so to manure is based around funding
for programs and projects delivering
Play Active Recreation and Sport
experiences for tamariki and rangatahi
especially those that are less active
people with disabilities women and girls
are in high deprivation areas
um it looks to make ensure that we're
helping young people to be active in
ways that they want and in ways that
meet their own needs
um the one I've got up there noted as a
a notable story is that it's really
interesting to see what the different
impacts and outcomes and how they vary
across these projects and some of them
are I suppose sort of left of field and
the example being the girls yoga group
that was set up via consultation with
the youth workers at the community
networking trust and one of the major
impacts I've heard
um via stories from the staff it's still
an ongoing project is that one of the
young girls fell asleep in a yoga class
and that was like a super highlight for
her youth worker as a student that
relatively High Strung is probably the
words to use and this young girl after
weeks of learning yoga and getting
involved feeling confident in her
surroundings and with her peers fell
asleep and that's the kind of you never
know what the important impacts might be
for an individual so it's quite a cool
story from them
supporting volunteers obviously a huge
part of active wreck and Sport across
communities as the volunteer network
that we have as you can see from New
Zealand over 1 million adults have um
participated in volunteering or
supported a group in the last 12 months
which is a pretty impressive number
for us recently in the area we hosted a
session from the New Zealand amateur
sports Association and we had it at the
gore Modi Sports Center it was a project
partnered with SDC and GDC to bring them
down and talk our local groups through
the changes that are coming in the
Incorporated societies Act and the time
frames that they've got to to work
through those there was a bit of um
people were a bit worried about it so it
was quite good for them to have a chance
to sit down hear about it talk through
it their concerns and ask their
questions we even had Groups travel from
otago to come to our one here in Gore so
we had over 10 groups represented that
day we also took some feedback from
those groups that day and and looking
for information on where they would like
further support and I think it's
intended that further support will be
coming out in time to support those
groups and those kind of volunteers
through this process obviously it's
quite daunting when you're a volunteer
and not a specialist in this area so
quite important to be able to support
those guys where we can
and I talked on the program locally
a project we have between ourselves
called medical and Gore Health
it's
helping with
appointments to help people with
becoming more active better eating and
decreasing these stress and locally
we've had 537 new appointments to
support people through that these it's
important locally for increasing things
like productivity and by increasing
people's effects activity we're helping
increase their health outcomes the
quality of life and decreasing sickness
and absenteeism and these appointments
are completely free to our registered
members at those two medical centers
in the last one I'll touch on and I'm
conscious that we're taking your time
thank you for this
um as the environmental well-being so
um provision of green spaces for play
sport active Rec and the infrastructure
for active Transportation can support
the achievement environmental and
Community wellbeing outcomes
specifically creation of
pro-environmental attitudes and
behaviors more environmentally friendly
Urban environments reduced admissions
from active transport and obviously
improve well-being from being active in
your natural environment
the example that we currently work
really closely with GDC on as part of
the spaces and places program and the I
think it's going to be on your agenda a
bit later as well but broadly this is a
strategy as a result of a collaboration
between ourselves sport New Zealand ICC
yourselves South and district and then
our community funders and it was born
out of a willingness by councils and
funders to work together to create and
Implement a more aligned approach to the
regional planning of spaces and places
um
some of those realities you'll see there
but otherwise I might just hand over to
UOB
um and just to go up on the last slide
just back it up one juices
um just to note that
um sitting alongside the strategy as an
active advisory committee made up of all
councils and Community funders as well
as active Southland to uh
essentially connect and understand
valuable data and insights for Effective
robust decision making it's not designed
to replace or supersede any sort of
autonomous agency that every
organization such as yourself has but
what it is designed to do is provide you
with really robust data and insights
with which you can be informed to make
your decision
and noting that this potentially is in
your agenda later on you know we have
aspirations in our aspiration is that
Frameworks such as this have a viable
relevancy in your in your processes that
frames Frameworks like this coupled with
advisory committees that are working
with this type of data are used to
inform your management plans your master
plans your your reviews when they happen
and the intent is to support you towards
robust decision making so our aspiration
as they eventually that there would be
an endorsement from Council to actively
work alongside and have this Frameworks
front of Mind where relevant in and
across your various plans and
um
thank you very much
um talking about aspirations I think the
one key a couple of key things I want to
pull off this slide before I wrap up is
that we have opportunity
to leverage and to bring to your
community learnings that we're seeing
not only within our wider region but
within our country as well so we're part
of a collective of regional Sports
trusts which are actively working in
this space so we're learning all the
time about things like active transport
we're currently working with a couple of
other partners and developing these
active transport plans and how we how
they look in each Community is quite
different but we work alongside
non-government organizations
Community groups as well as councils to
to look at relevant plans that might
help in this space Not only from a
climate action perspective but also
about that physical well-being space and
utilizing physical activity and movement
for those wider benefits
also just acknowledging the value of
green space and open spaces and not only
to be there but how we might support
councils to actively utilize these
spaces in partnership with Community
organizations so again we're we're
prototyping we're piloting a whole lot
of opportunities not only within Gore
District but but the wider region as
well and so just indicating we have
aspirations to support you in this space
depending on where you head to with your
long-term plans and your goals
um so just to wrap up
um I just want to say a massive thank
you to you as Council for our continued
investment not just for the investment
but the partnership and collaboration
that happened that has happened
alongside the investment and so you need
one alongside the other and so we say
thank you for that and we make a promise
that for the investment that will follow
and that we're advocating for
um that will bring everything that we
have as an organization to leverage that
dollar that you provide us with we have
various teams in our organization that
range from events through to our uh our
teams that operate in in primary and
secondary school our teams that operate
amongst ngos and charitable trusts and
Incorporated societies that we bring
their learnings in their arms and legs
where we can to leverage outcomes in
terms of Board District and to support
the outcomes and aspirations of your
community so again we thank you and um
and and pass it back over to you but
thank you very much
thank you for that presentation that was
very informative are there any questions
councilor Paul mcphail through the chief
just asking
the um
the population of Gore's aging a lot I
just want to know whether you're hitting
you have anything to do with the other
end of the scale you've got a lot of
kids or organization is there anything
you actually deal with for the older
people yeah
uh yeah absolutely and acknowledging
absolutely that population Trends we're
staying on top of those as much as we
can and just looking at obviously
waiting for census data to come out but
I think we know what they're going to
say is that the population continues to
age and that we need to be mindful and
thoughtful about how we provide for
every single age group in our population
and so we have initiatives that we CA
that currently cater for age groups
whether they be younger and or older in
green prescription is a perfect example
toku urang is a great enough another
great example of that and we're
currently working alongside the likes of
regional sporting organizations and
clubs to look at how how our provisions
and our offerings relevant to the
populations and communities where they
find themselves so we are We Are One
organization but we actually work along
in and alongside a whole bunch of other
organizations that we're actively
advocating in encouraging the use of
data such as the one that you raised to
challenge and advocate for our
population as as we see it changing
councilor Richard mcvale
sorry I know we're running against time
but yeah great report uh probably
statement and one question uh great to
see praise for Keith and E score
particularly around uh all the
tamariki's running around trying to work
out what the best gear is and that sort
of thing
um questioners uh
is there enough over there like is there
what we have there I'm probably going
against what the Holocaust I said for
the young the youth that are in East
Gore
because we've got Oxford Street and then
we've got Hamilton park across the main
road
um
did they express or do they state that
it was sufficient there the other thing
is did they point out any other areas
kids supporting having the other areas
that they play and that we don't know
about
and the other thing is obviously taken
congressants that we've got mad eye
registers coming online and hopefully
we're going to have some lovely families
moving in there with more kids so yeah I
think it's a really great initiative
that you're doing some work over there
fantastic yeah any response to that yeah
so
um yes the kids so far have been
exceedingly happy with what's gone down
so far haven't they Keith so
um but as I mentioned in the project if
I haven't included the entire reporting
with this but they were phased
um aspects of what else was to come
um so things like adding to the
amenities so that they were toilet and
for changing facilities making more of
those spaces that are there and have
been improved to this point just a
little bit further so that families can
come along and enjoy them
across age groups we've taken into
consideration things like
um seating of different heights so that
a person who's got a little bit more
difficulty with getting down and getting
back up again has an appropriate option
compared to a kid who can jump over top
of any seats so we've definitely taken
an on board the voice of the tamariki
they were the core group from the start
of that project but it has become wider
than that it's now a what we recall an
intergenerational project so it takes
into aspects everything
um yes the kids went to lots of places
further than those playgrounds we had
information around what they do down at
the river how they're access getting
across the main road for example kids
having to go all the way down under the
bridge to come back around to cross to
the other side but interestingly when
you mentioned about Hamilton Park there
um the tamariki very really referenced
Hamilton Park from that aspect that they
can't safely get across there so the
conversations that have been happening
around those Crossings and stuff
happening on the road there will be
really important for ensuring that those
spaces that are there and have the
facilities in them the kids can actually
access let alone mum did Grandma and
everybody else so yeah
so I'll read thank you madam chair
um thank you for your presentation very
good I will I do have a couple of
questions and I'll try and squish them
together
um given the fact that traditional
Sports have dropped off
um
there's got to be a way forward for
other sports and I'm thinking how do you
encourage the kids that are left school
and have never really engaged in
physical Sports other than
keeping their thumbs busy
um
and it worries me that because sports
are organized through schools along with
organizations like yourselves that there
is that lapse at the other end in the
middle and then you've actually got
sedentary adults before you know where
you were so just interested in what you
see going forward with that yeah so we
haven't cracked this
um but um it is it is our whole focus in
terms of how do we actually understand
the changing needs and wants of our
young people
in sport while it while there is
decreasing
participation it is important to
acknowledge that it still forms a really
important part of our community and
their pockets of our community still
love live and breathe our sport so it's
not one or the other it's both but I
think
people also vote with their with their
hands and their wallets and so the more
that we can ready the sports sector to
provide offerings that are different and
that meet the needs of our community the
better off where we'll be as a whole
we are currently working with
non-traditional sport providers when I
say that I mean things like alternative
education
non-government organizations and young
people who may not Walk and Walk In
traditional methods of education and or
um
you know your your mainstream sort of
methods of engaging with Community they
are equally as important so we're
working with non-traditional providers
to look at offerings that are um that
may be more interested and more relevant
to young people wanting to engage and
then leading into more active
Lifestyles leading forward from that so
a tracky complex sort of space but we
are continuously
evolving in trying to evaluate our
impact in this
circular area thank you because also
those sporting activities which whatever
they be involve a social connection as
well which is really important correct
so I thank you for your work thank you
very much
any further questions
councilor Phillips my mind on equation
mine is just a a congratulations
director of Southland
um
for the service to our Council I believe
we're getting an A plus service for the
money that we're getting that we're
thank you very much and keep up the good
work guys you've done doing a good job
appreciate that thank you very much
any further questions
you worship
thank you madam chair um just a question
we talked a little bit about partnership
we've talked a little bit about a
decline in sports
we've just been gifted a lovely tennis
court plus Club rooms
um that I guess we're starting to
discuss just be interested to see what a
partnership there might look like moving
forward I'm sure our staff were some
fantastic ideas but it might be a space
for us to both work in absolutely I
think um look there's complexities and
all of that and you know the
complexities of holding assets and
managing assets is tricky enough in
itself
but the types of things that we would
explore include you know current
participation of those Sports what is
what is the participation of there and
what is the likelihood of that
particular sport actually growing in
that particular community and that might
dictate then how much investment the
council might like to put forward into
that into the future and so a large part
of this is for framed within the
regional spaces and places strategy
about what good looks like and how do
you use a framework like that for
decision making so really encourage you
to have a look at that and think about
how you might utilize a framework like
that but equally so in collaboration
with the likes of Earth spaces and
places the advisory committee even just
to talk through what good could look
like I know in the currently we've been
supporting clubs who have momentum and
appetite to work together and I'll use
an example about Winton as a just an
example where we have a group of around
13 clubs who have an interest in working
together so we're currently bringing
them together to help facilitate what
does this look like and So within the
strategy you'll see Frameworks like
Concepts like multi-use and hubbing or
networked facilities which basically
reflect the limited amount of resources
that we all have and so therefore the
resources that we have need to be
utilized to its maximum so that we can
ensure that we care for the things that
we have but we also ensure that the
things that we have are relevant and
meet the needs of our community not just
a small pocket of our community but the
largest part of our communities as well
so those are just some of the initial
things and Frameworks that come to mind
when we consider an example like that
any further questions
well thank you very much for your
presentation Vanessa Gemma and Jess
um thank you for all the good work and
Marty that active self and does for the
gold district to keep our community
healthy and active appreciate your
presentation thank you
we're now on to item two which is on
page 18. proposed South and Community
Foundation
just wondering
um Rex do you have anything to add to
the notes
a statement report has read
um
and as I say in the report it's really
just an initial presentation provided by
the consultant wanting to socialize that
with you as a council
and and be aware that this is going to
be work in progress over the next um I'd
say I'd suggest two to five years and in
creating some sort of foundation for it
to advance you'll notice in one of the
slides that Southland is well of a few
regions that doesn't have a foundation
um and uh there's there is a real
momentum being gained
um for this to be Advanced and I think
it's just something that Council has an
awareness of
um and obviously once it gets
established we become a good partner to
be involved with
any questions or rest
Council appraiser
chair Rex I I recently we probably
haven't got it is because our Community
Trust was so buoyant at probably one of
the most successful Community trusts in
the country that has continued on but my
only fear is it's just another funding
organization looking for money from the
same pool
attract iot ort Foundation money but
it's just that's my only fear
um from generous gifting from the
community not another fund setting up
thank you councilry
sorry I was just about to make the point
that it was also from my point
benefactors of the community who would
set up that trust and that money would
be gifted or left
via donations or am I right or wrong
that's how I understand it
rich
councilor Phillips
um thank you manager a prime example
would be the best Luther one with the
funding they're just put into the new
community into their Center it was quite
an established amount
any further questions or comments
with someone like to move that the
report be received I think your
councilor Reed counselor Paul mcphail
seconded all in favor
Carrie
Council read not quite sure where to
remove the active Southern report be
reserved
we moved it it was just we didn't do we
need to move it yeah would someone thank
you for that would someone move that
thank you Council read seconded
councilor Phillips
to move on to item three which is page
32 the Gould District Community campus
quarterly report for 2023
is there anything for the I'd like to
add to that not really Madam chair just
um reinforce that this is a good touch
point for us as a council to get an
understanding it's a subscription I
think um Sonia that we have we have had
involvement with for three years now and
one of the things that we think is
important is that it is brought to your
attention for like I say that since
touch sense point but also it's now
public document and the community have
access to that information as much as
you as a council so it's a it's a good
starting point for some of those
conversations
questions please
a more procedural one and this might not
be the right forum for it but is this
not duplicating a lot of the information
that we get from Infamous
infometrics has generally one-off
projects the Great South
um have commissioned for the strategy
work as I understand it I know that we
have in some instances engaged in for
metrics but we haven't during war as
part of this process I don't think
assistance through the chair
um no we don't use infometrics that much
as as the um as Rick said we use it for
runoff projects mainly through Great
South but this actually replaces the
information it's instead of
thank you
Council Reed Indian Council thank you
madam chair
um it's I really like the data it's
right across the board and it's quite
detailed
um surprisingly and one of the things
that jumped out and
smacked me in the face was the increase
of
um crime in waikaka yeah I'm sorry that
came across a bit flip but you know a
rural community
um at quite a distance from police and
fire
um you know interesting statistic
it's interesting too that deprivation
index didn't show why keiko's being low
so
um yeah that was an interesting point
any further questions
I just I think this is very interesting
information that could feed into our ltp
that we need to keep it in mind just in
the background
so could I have someone move that the
report be received thank you councilor
appraiser counselor
read
all in favor
to move to item four page 44 update on
Regional Recreation strategies the South
and sports field strategy and miraaku
South and spaces in places strategy and
you'll note the attachment that went
with that
anything further to add to that
oh it's even these are the two reports
that um Vanessa was referring to
um before back to South and in terms of
the uh spaces and places Advisory Group
that is in existence which we have
representation of from both myself and
Keith and Keith was also a key player in
the sports field strategy development
work so I think it's a good example of
that partnership that we actively
participate as equal Partners in those
working groups at that staff level
um
a couple of things I would add
it is also worthwhile for us matara
license and Trust have representative on
the spaces and places working group as
well and and it's also so that's good
from uh um local relationship and local
partnership perspective to actually
start to cross the wires that that are
on the on the on the plate for the MLT
as much as it is as wood Council and
then also look at it from that Regional
perspective of what the um that Advisory
Group does
I I mean the both of the strategies are
attached
um the spaces in place and strategy and
the sports field strategy what I am
interested in I suppose is how we
utilize these going forward
so one of the things that I'm working
with Keith on
um is obviously as part of our active
sport or active Recreation activity
management plans
what if anything out of these and
there's some recommendations which I
have highlighted in the cover report
that are there on page 45 of just for
the recommendation to receive the report
in italics they've tried to pull out
some of those specific
recommendations out of the strategies
that we are now considering at a staff
level as to what that might mean for our
program of work if anything and one of
the things that we will probably come
back to the full council with is if
there's anything that needs
consideration for work to be undertaken
as a result of being recommended in
these Regional strategies for you to
consider as a council it'll come through
that activity management planning
process and the resource required as
part of the long-term plan
so that's the first point I would just
signal and interested in if any
conversation around that today but just
putting it on the putting it on the
radar that that will come back to you as
a full Council uh it's part of our
long-term planning process the second
thing is you will and I was sitting in
the conversation at one of your previous
meetings at the modeling Council I think
it was Council where you were talking
about
um the taking over of the asset or asset
slash liability of of a community
Pavilion type thing on our reserves this
is the sort of work that starts to
inform some of that and while you were
talking about incorporating it into your
reserve management plan
um conversations in the working group
associated with that there's also the
opportunity to um I think as part of our
renegotiations with active Southland and
some of you alluded to it to alluded to
it today that we start some
conversations with active self and
around getting some of that external
support to facilitate some of those
conversations as well so those are just
some initial points I would like to flag
and interested in your feedback and
comments around any of this work at a
regional level but how it impacts with
us locally
thank you weeks are there any um
questions comments feedback
counselor Reed sorry um just a question
for Rex further to what you were just
saying about the Preston Street Court
what happens if
um the two sports concerned don't that's
something that we need to look forward
to forward with as well that if that
falls over with those two groups what
sport
can we use that space for
I agree and that would be part of the
process of the discussions that we would
need to be looking at at either future
proofing or understanding what and how
that might be able to utilize going for
any further
to Richard mcvale yep just just through
to Rex
um just confirming so the strategies
that are there
uh that we're feeding into the work that
we're hearing from the other projects
that are going on may help you with your
work is that what we're saying so that
we're not crossing over we're not
doubling up we're not okay that's fine
I'll just remember I took it that's what
you were saying one of the things that
I'm quite
um
uh unusual as you would probably expect
blunt or direct about when um dealing
with these advisory groups is
you know we strategy is only effective
if it's in in language that is able to
be utilized and implemented and worked
through and aligned with the last thing
we want are these strategies that sit
because they are too far removed from
the the local where the where the action
happens so that's one of the things that
both Keith and I have have constantly
referred back to in these conversations
and the other thing that I am very
conscious of having um
being in this game for a bit too long is
that Consultants who you bring in to do
these reports generally will will
provide recommendations that potentially
have about another 10 jobs for them that
can come out of it and that's one thing
that we've we've been um we've been
quite uh clever on or when I say clever
we've been quite clear on in terms of
making sure that again we are not just
going to go down that path and that's
why I'm talking about us introducing
this into our activity management plan
so that we can be directly involved and
understand what that might mean from a
resource perspective
interesting
okay Council Mackenzie you were trying
to remember my name weren't you
um just the comment on Hamilton Park
for overflow for football possibly in
the back of my mind there's something
telling me that they tried to play
football over there and the ground was a
bit
too Humpty bumpy
that's just for some reason that's in
the back of my mind but um if it's just
for an overflow is it suitable
would it be suitable for an overflow for
football I would just um answering your
question
um currently it's probably too wet to um
be a great soccer field or football
field yeah
yeah um
it's a work in progress and and a lot of
the site was also a former landfill so
it was there was material that's quite
close to the surface
that will be brought up I've been trying
to try and it'll do anything with it
councilor Phillips
I think you're into here I this is
probably just a question for Rex then um
are you looking possibly then to have a
workshop on this
have you got a specific date or
just to Carry On from the other Workshop
bits yeah I think what we would tip to
do counselor Phillips is is introduced
as when we start to talk about the
activity management plans and if there's
anything in Greater detail that comes
out of that we can Workshop that
um but I'm happy to take advice and
direction in terms of if there's some
things Offline that we specifically want
to focus on then we can we can factor in
a particular website I think we're going
to tie it into our Reserve management
plan working group stuff as well and and
just start to align all of these things
that are spinning and spinning into
places are spinning and bring them down
together
any further comments or questions you
worship
thank you madam chair I guess it's a
follow-up that conversation has been
circling around my head of this Reserve
management plan group
while everything fits in this it seems
to be getting away from its original
purpose so
um I can see Keith's kind of wanting to
stay a bit focused on that so I wonder
whether whether it's the same membership
or whatever the case may be a different
structure we could look into if they can
that same group so we're all dealing
with the same base of knowledge
um but keeping it separate to the
reserve management plan I don't know
what that looks like but maybe something
to have a think about
oh
Council Phillips
yeah I see we've got a scheduled meeting
on Thursday so we could probably have a
bit of a discussion about that anyway on
how long the structure has gone
any further comments
I just I just feel that with the
changing face of sport and their climate
that we need to make sport viable and
sustainable as well so I I think that
the strategy will help to do that
someone like to recommend that the
report be received and that the council
know the South and sports field strategy
July 2023 in the South and spaces and
places strategy 2023 some light to move
that councilor Richard mcvale
seconded you worship
all those in favor
carried
just move on now to item five page 48
ready for living and the age friend
friendly strategy
2023-27 and
or Kylie do you have some anything to
add to the report
okay thank you Madam's here College just
going to give you
the summary documented an A3 because
you've got it it's the last page in your
agenda and it'll just be a little bit
easier for you to read
um I think I'm sure most of you will
realize that really for living started
this journey about five years ago
and it was very much
a collective of community people and
some agencies that had strong Vision
that Gore had an aging population and at
that point go ahead
the largest
older population in the country now
we're third on the list waitaki and
Central otago have more older people or
people older over 65 than we do
um so if I picking up on Rex's comment
about strategies those of you who know
me I'm a person that might do strategies
but I actually want to implement
Implement them and um I think we've
tried very hard to put this in our
community's language so this started in
November last year where I facilitated
five workshops and I do want to
acknowledge Kylie for her work in this
document
because there has been a lot of work
going behind the scenes and also Rebecca
McRae
but part of the thing that we really
wanted to do was to ask our older
community to come and have conversations
with us and so we made sure we had
smaller groups and we started those by
basically saying to them that you know
would they spend a couple of hours with
us and tell us about their journey in
life and what has been tough harder or
indifferent and what should we be
thinking about that we need to do
differently for those that are coming
next
and actually that proved to be very
successful
we
talked first off to our community and
then we ran workshops with the agencies
that provide services to our older
people and we tested the information we
had with our agencies and they actually
added some more value around in a bit
more detail I guess would be the way to
put it
so from that we have this document
uh I guess what we're seeing across New
Zealand now when we first had the first
work plan and Kylie came to the gore
District Council
two years ago yeah so this is year three
of her being here and for some of you
might not realize that core Council
doesn't fund her salary it's funded
through pH Victory trust and we
approached them last year and they
agreed to funds to the 30th of June next
year
so we have that funding confirmed and
then to to implement projects that were
on that original project plan we've
sourced other bits and pieces of funding
or we've partnered with organizations
that have been Keen to work with us to
get things across the line but
there's probably about five or six other
councils now in New Zealand that have
done age-friendly strategies and people
are starting to realize that this is a
not just a school district this is a
global and national and local issue
around aging and it's it's
needing an environment to think about
things differently of what we will need
in the future when we're making
decisions
there's eight key areas that most of
those strategies and are recognized
internationally which are those things
on page 47 of your agenda the outdoor
spaces and buildings transportation and
Mobility housing social participation
respect and social inclusion and civic
participation and employment and in
community support in our health services
which we've talked quite a bit about
today in communication and information
so if we can get all of those things
right or improved and we improve the
social inclusion and we reduce isolation
and Kylie often says to me in her work
that she hears of people that are quite
isolated or we constantly heard in our
conversations about people that are
lonely and I guess one of the challenges
is trying to connect with those people
and find ways to improve that situation
and our community
and the spin-off if we aren't doing
those things well is we see cognitive
decline in depression and other health
issues so if we get it right we have a
far better mental health within our
community and it's really important that
our older people
maintain their independence and their
autonomy and their well respected and
there is such a shift now to have people
staying in their homes longer instead of
if you looked back 10 years the move was
to put more people into like
service living like Rest Homes Etc
so with that we have to make sure that
we've got the right services that can
actually support people to stay in their
homes
so on this document that you've got
these little Circles of housing
employment volunteerism health and
well-being communication information
Recreation Mobility accessibility and
safety those were the key priorities
that our community said they wanted us
to work on and then the
the bullet points alongside those are a
very quick snapshot of what's in the
document just to make it easy for for
people to get an understanding about
what we're going to focus on
I guess I think at that point maybe I'll
just leave it open for questions if
you've got any questions after reading
the strategy that you'd like to ask
myself or Kylie
and the main purpose I guess today is we
want to get you to sign off the strategy
so that we can start working on it but
we also want to alert you that we want
to have a conversation through the
long-term plan process with a view to
fund one full-time equivalent
to maintain and further develop this
work
other equations please
I'm just after an interesting article
and stuff a couple of months ago about
Boomers like myself or getting into the
retirement age who have been renting all
their lives and the affordability to
stay stay in a place like Gore who are
leaving do we have any sort of numbers
on how many that is so we're looking
elsewhere to live because we're not
being able to provide
the basics of housing for them or not us
as but the community hasn't been up to
um I think we don't actually have any
hard data but in the conversations
um there was a lot of information of the
challenges people were having around
housing and one of those was about
competing with young people so now we've
got young people in the same Market
looking for no Gardens maybe two
bedrooms and that was elevating the
price and there was a lot of older
people said that like they couldn't
afford to downsize from their big family
homes
there wasn't the type of living that
they would like and Gore so there's no
Indigent or intergenerational spaces
there's limited rental as well so there
is a piece of housing work that we need
to do trying to look at all of those
aspects the other thing we do know about
Gore is that people have left Gore like
for central otago for example but then
we're seeing people coming back from
Central otago and maybe moving into rest
homes or into smaller properties here
because they've got family here
so the answers we haven't got any hard
data but there's been a lot of
conversations with people to understand
what the challenges are
councilor Reed yup sorry guys sorry
finished accounts appraiser did you get
another question so going forward if
we've got this coming into our long-term
plan we will be needing to get data to
actually push forward
from that would we not
so the thing we're going to be asking in
the long-term plan is about having the
staff person to work on this because
without the people resource we can't
actually do any of the work so there
will be a piece around housing and we
expect that we'll build up a scope about
what that work will look like and then
we would have to find some funding to to
do that piece of work
counselor Reed
thank you madam chair a couple of things
there it's interesting that times have
changed and as you say in they're
encouraging some of us older people to
stay in our own homes but of course that
also precludes a lot of people from
buying another family home so it's a bit
of a vicious circle
and the other thing too is that locally
and I know specifically of there's a lot
of women on their own who have to rent
it's actually becoming
very very expensive and they're caught
between the devil and the deep blue sea
trying to find somewhere where they can
live after paying rent and the only way
forward I think for the district is
maybe for the ready for loving group and
whoever that may entail at the time
working with government to have some
sort of
housing
for elderly people perhaps connected to
other housing so that there's some sort
of social interaction as wet well with
that but I'd really like to see us push
for that I think that that's one of the
main drivers in our community that
causes a lot of worry for our senior
citizens
sorry through the chair um I'm a bit of
a dollars and sense person and maybe
might not be the right Forum but I'd
like to know the funding what funding
we're looking at you know we need down
the track and what you're looking for so
that we can
get a bit of an idea so so
um
Council mcphail that'll be the next
piece of work once this is signed off
and we will be coming back in the ltp
with some figures for you yeah
Council of Richard mcphail
thank you for that and uh yeah I love
you know a total support of the relief
for living project and um it's great to
see that the seeds have been planted
that are starting to come out on the
side so yeah look at uh great support
for that uh and it's actually getting
quite um
and you say it uh concise we're actually
starting to identify
from a huge playing field down to some
really really good stuff and I think
it's I think it's great I'm looking at
it here today uh so yeah total support
great presentation and um totally behind
us happy with it uh probably what uh
other councilman Powell said would be
around making sure we have the funding
uh like what it's going to cost us we're
going to get a long-term plan and just
confirming we are over with the Vickery
trust there's no nothing we can go back
there put some appears that we could
have another crack that's it and we have
a great relationship with Patrick trust
we did apply for three years funding and
they gave us one we're not totally sure
why that is but it could be that we were
embarking on the strategy process and
now we have like clear information about
the strategy so I do intend to go back
and talk to them
um they at that time they were looking
for bigger projects so they may maybe a
partner in the housing space
um
who knows but
we haven't forgotten them we talked to
them regularly Kylie give some very good
reports so my intention is that I will
go to Christchurch and will present the
strategy to them and have a conversation
thanks for that
councilor McKenzie
um and a question for you I look on an
air senior citizens that I am one year
off becoming
one of
um there's a massive resource of
Knowledge and Skills there was here
senior citizens
I'll give you an example the guy that
lives next door to me is an English
person and he was one of the main people
that designed the windows for Concord
he held you know there's people around
that have got these skills that I'm sure
they would like to share and whether
they be trade people or things like that
do we look at for those kind of folk
that could participate and probably
enjoy being part of that community
so to answer that question and when we
had discussions about volunteerism it
was really interesting because it was
probably a three-way mix of people who
said no I've done my time I don't want
to volunteer I've been involved in every
Club you can imagine all of my life and
now this is my time and then there was
people that said that it was incredibly
difficult to volunteer and get involved
and then there was others that said
it's really simple and often those
people were people that had had a whole
life in Goa and Gore district and are
well connected and other pieces of work
that we're doing in our team with
Workforce volunteerism and exactly what
you were talking about has come up of
utilizing expertise and seeing how they
could work
with businesses or other community
organizations so actually right now
we're having a bit of a conversation
with a volunteers organization to see
see what we could do
to connect people in that space
so I think yes we do need to utilize
those expertise thank you
any further comments questions
thank you very much for the report Kylie
and Ian oh sorry we're here sorry it's
me again counselor Reed I just want to
acknowledge the hard work by Anne and
also by Kylie
um it's really as Richard said it's been
a long time in the planet well not that
long but long enough in the planning but
the fact that I think we've communicated
with so many different people across so
many different spaces
um just bodes well for where we're
heating with it so thank you both
thank you a n Carly for the work that
you've done across this with 26 of our
population going to be over 65 in 2033 I
think it's very important that we're age
friendly
and our support and thank you for the
work that you're doing
just finishing
um could I have a recommendation that
the report be received and that the
funding be considered as part of the
council's ltp effective from the 1st of
July 2024.
someone moves that can counselor Fraser
secondary
councilor Phillips all in favor
carried
thank you councilors and I'll call the
meeting to a close at 6 15 p